hello youtubers this is Sergey I'm here
at Davos and have lots of exciting
conversations here I just got this
question I saw about voting and what can
we do to improve it I think a really
important part of voting's have a public
that's engaged educated and and really
interested in all the key issues as well
as the candidate positions and that's
why I think that YouTube is a great
platform for that we've started with the
debates having questions come in
directly from all of you but I think
there's lots more opportunity for
engagement to form greater communities
around important issues so you're not
just getting all sound bytes but you can
actually delve deeper into these issues
and discuss them but at a very deep
level with both experts around the field
and just many ordinary interests of the
citizens so I'm a big fan of education
and engagement when it comes to voting